hey folks welcome to reality check the
once was an idea that was the gamer a
shut-in
a recluse a person forced to look to
digital interaction to really fit in and
to find meaning in society more than
just that though I'm sure we've all
heard the mainstream stereotype that
online gamers used digital worlds as an
analogue or replacement for real-life
interactions and that these scenarios
make it easier for the socially
maladjusted to converse with others
without some of the messiness or
friction of real-life engagement now you
and I as people who play games we all
have a wealth of anecdotal observations
for why this just isn't true
unfortunately though this notion does
persist amongst certain groups of
society well thankfully we now have some
hard science we can show these people
and help disprove this myth once and for
all and that's what this week's reality
check is all about
public displays of play studying online
games in physical settings is a study
headed up by researchers at North
Carolina State University and the paper
published in the Journal of computer
mediated communication the researchers
revealed that online gaming can
supplement or even enhance gamers social
lives rather than inhibiting them in the
words of lead author dr. Nick Taylor
gamers aren't the antisocial basement
dwellers we see in pop culture
stereotypes they're highly social people
loners are the outliers in gaming not
the norm so how did they demonstrate
this while the researchers analyzed the
behavior of thousands of online gamers
most notably those who play MMOs like
world Warcraft and EVE Online they
attended a large number of different
industry events in Canada and the UK
now these included large and small land
parties fan conventions internet cafes
and pub based gaming nights alongside
these large observations and interviews
the researchers also carried out a
smaller scale but in-depth survey of 378
gamers focusing on how they communicated
with others their goal was to track both
the online and offline behavior of
gamers focusing on how they communicated
with one another their overwhelmingly
they observed that gaming was just one
aspect of social behavior going on at
these events once again in the words of
dr. Taylor we find that gamers were
often exhibiting many social behaviors
at once watching games talking drinking
and chatting online now while some of
the settings observed where gamers
played such as internet cafes with
segregated cubicles did discourage
offline interaction this was very much
in the minority
conversely local area network or LAN
parties gaming conventions and pub based
gaming meetups all supplemented or
enhanced gamers overall social
connectedness in the study the example
of LAN parties was highlighted
explaining that these were most often
played with friends romantic partners or
guild mates so for most people the
purpose of being there was to take part
in both the online and offline
interactions interestingly this was true
regardless of which games gamers are
actually playing and all
regardless of how they behaved in-game
so if they're playing in a heavily
adversarial way this did not appear to
translate to the real-world interactions
a player could be utterly ruthless in
the game and still socialize normally
offline this ties in nicely to another
thing said by the research team now they
make the case that what goes on in an
MMO should not be thought of as an
analog or an alternative to what goes on
in real life they argue that we
shouldn't think of players as either
being here in the real world or there
online but rather that one is meshed
with in the other in essence remember
that it is just a game and that the vast
majority of people who play online games
maintain that sense of perspective one
thing dr. Taylor and the rest of the
team did note however is that this work
focused on Western gaming community
specifically and that there could well
be social differences and therefore
different results were this test to be
replicated in other gaming cultures and
that this is something they'd like to
look into in the future so what did you
make of this study let me know in the
comments also if you'd like to have a
read of the paper yourself then head on
over to my blog which is tinyurl.com
/cam france blog and they'll be a link
there alternatively if you're watching
on youtube then that link is also in the
description
last week on reality check I did a
call-out for potential future topics and
I got a ton of great suggestions
especially over Twitter user Levy Smith
suggested you should do a reality check
episode of Batman and if his gadgets are
possible he'll - Rocksteady Bill Hudson
asked what causes a civilization just
one more turn mentality and Atsuto
Kieran said do shields like in Star Trek
or Halo or Thor or any sci-fi thing
thank you very much for those ideas guys
I've added them all to the list now if
you have a suggestion or would like to
get in touch with me about anything else
then just hit me up on Twitter at kam
fries Rob thanks for watching
you